[Music]
oh my god guys can't Rock is so bad I
know I kind of sound like a giggling
idiot saying that but I'm sorry it's
really hard not to laugh when talking
about this movie it is just so bad okay
it's not as surreal as can of worms or
as annoying as Cheetah Girls but it
really is kind of amazing how they hit
every single possible cliche you could
do with this story where do I even begin
I'll start at the beginning cuz yeah
it's like everything immediately seems
awkward and out of place even from the
start there's this high school girl
named Mitchie who's really excited to go
to Camp Rock but it looks like her
parents aren't able to have her go but
then it turns out they can yes that's
the opening what was the point of that
she finds out she can't go she mopes for
maybe a minute and then the parents are
so excited they tell her that they can't
go because they're catering there and
she's excited again why wasn't that
edited out I'll tell you exactly why
because they saw in other movies this
cliche where somebody is sad they can't
go to a place but then happy when they
find out they can even though they don't
really grasp that that goes through a
long time and there's ups and downs
peaks and valleys and arches and stuff
like that no you just need a minute of
this not yet developed character sulking
and then suddenly being happy and that's
pretty much how the rest of the film
works just trying to cram in as many
cliches as possible they can't even
juggle them all you see the Jonas
Brothers oh wait I'm sorry not the Jonas
Brothers a completely different band has
the lead singer who's acting out and
totally forgetting what it means to be
about the music so his band members drop
him off at Camp Rock to hope he will
regain his voice yeah because a
teenybopper pop singer surrounded by
teeth is gonna help him discover his
voice isn't that what do you already get
even the first scene we have with him
and Mitchie at the camp is just a mix of
too many cliches he's running away from
a bunch of girls so he hides in a bush
she suddenly gets an urge to play in the
piano you know be herself and play her
little solo that she wrote I think the
idea is that he's supposed to hear her
music and be inspired but they don't
show any
thing like that she's playing and it
keeps cutting back to him but he's not
looking up at her or acting like he's
hearing anything he's just looking at
these girls he's trying to hide from
then she disappears then he goes inside
it's like plus anybody here oh okay so
you did hear what was in there how come
nothing on your face indicated that how
come none of the editing indicated that
well no time to answer that we have to
get to all our incredibly cliched
characters like the popular bully who
apparently runs the camp well how does a
teen pop singer run a camp even the
snarky best friend stereotype is like
yeah music doesn't fly here it's all
about the bling that's why she runs the
camp but it's okay because Michie of
course makes up a lie that her parents
are incredibly popular and presidents of
companies and stuff like that
and she's totally been in a lot of music
videos and oh oh well that lie be
revealed somewhere down the road well
again we have no time for that cliche
because we had to get to the cliche of
the Jonas Brother just sitting alone and
saying he doesn't like being a label he
wants to work in his own music and not
this cookie cutter stuff uh news flash
jackass the guy sitting alone on the
beach playing his guitar is also a label
you're a living proof of that being a
Jonas Brother acting out this cliche but
up we have to get to the cliche of the
bully girl throwing food at another girl
but it's okay because she'll still
sabotage her by interrupting her
performance saying that she saw a snake
this okay so got interrupted the girl
can go right back to play up no she's
too mad apparently she can't keep
playing what reality is this in where
the hell are the counselors there's no
order at this place but apparently
that's still not enough cliche so the
bully girl makes it look like she stole
something from her oh my god this is
overload did anybody have an original
thought when making this but it's tragic
too because that bully girl it turns out
her mother is a pop star and doesn't
have time for her
ooh this film's deep guys so now Mitch
is a liar and apparently a thief but of
course it'll take some sort of big Jam
concert at the end to make everybody
okay Michie her best friend Jonas
brother number three even the bully girl
ends up being a best friend at the end
okay you know what I am
there needs to be some consequences I'm
usually for forgive and forgetting
everything but this is ridiculous what
number Disney Channel movie is this
where they just kiss and make up at the
end totally forget all the terrible
things they've done and they just allow
them to be friends again I know it's
good to be nice but I'm sorry there's
got to be some goddamn responsibility in
this world oh and by the way and answer
to the first question you were probably
asking when you saw this review the
answer is no the Jonas Brothers cannot
act we have a problem that actually I
don't really have a problem with that we
have a problem with that one word
payback that's two words by God is that
painful this film doesn't have a corny
charm like the high school musicals or
the Twitch's films it's just
manipulative beginning to end nothing
seems real nothing seems interesting
which is a shame because I think the
girl claimed the main lead actually
isn't that bad she's got this awkward
smile and okay delivery that I could
totally see working in another film but
here there's nothing she or any of these
cast members can do it's just every
cliche checklist you can imagine but
I'll be honest it's hard to say I didn't
kind of enjoy how bad it was I mean good
lord even the song sock for Jonah's
brother number three talking about
cookie cutter pop songs there sure are a
lot of cookie cutter pop songs in this
so yeah I can kind of see people looking
back on this and laughing the same way
we look back on Space Jam and laugh like
it's just so incredibly dominated but if
you're looking for a legitimately good
or charming movie I can easily say get
the rock out of here
[Music]
you